check check check check it should be the
same if you had it last time okay
[Music]
welcome everybody to another mob slash
food review and today is going to be a
special treat we are going to eat
something so quintessentially American
it's gonna blow the tip of your penis
off right into your eyelashes four of my
favorite top la burger joints now
technically some of these places aren't
just burger joints they have a lot of
other food there but these are the
burgers that I personally like by no
means does this actually mean that these
are the best burgers in LA I'm just
giving you my preference so whenever you
come to LA or if you do live in LA you
can go ahead and try it out and if you
like it you're gonna love me and then
you're gonna look at my penis like it's
a lollipop now I know what you're
thinking - David you look a little
Haggard you look a little sleepy you
look a little tired because guess what
[ __ ] is [ __ ] early in the morning
and I'm shooting this [ __ ] because the
first burger that we have is going to be
so important that it has to be in the
morning so without further ado do let's
get it eaten
yippee-kay-yay [ __ ] we got a
new contender in town now first up we
have a breakfast burger from this joint
in South Pasadena called costs and pie
now I know when a lot of people in LA
they're like well what the [ __ ] is this
place like I said [ __ ] it's a new
contender they just opened up but this
is a joint that I frequent a lot and
pretty often for breakfast and brunch so
a lot of people don't think about this
place when it comes to burgers so I'm
just gonna go ahead and crack this open
to show you what we have here now let's
go ahead and talk about what we have
here this right here is a house-made
brioche bun because they do have an
in-house baker and they bake all their
own [ __ ] we have a sunny-side up egg
there is a bacon marmalade type of like
jam I believe it's sweet its savory and
smoky from those bacon bits special
house sauce and an Angus patty in
between
so let me show you what we have here and
yes that goopy gloppy mess on the bottom
is like oh oh yeah this by the way is a
pretty messy burger so if you're
thinking about using a fork and knife
with this
I'd say [ __ ] you do not do that get in
there get messy and grub on that [ __ ] oh
my god oh my god
I'm sorry my face is all messed but it
has a sweetness Avery play that you have
it's because that's sweet onion jam that
they have and that smoky bacon in
between and then you of course you have
that delicious yoki egg and this soft
Rios bun oh you know if you have
cholesterol problems all I can say is
don't eat this burger but at the same
time if you don't mind dying why the
[ __ ] not you might we'll go out with a
bright bright night the house sauce that
they have on here is pretty freakin bomb
I don't know why it actually goes into
it but seems like some kind of Thousand
Island dressing oh yeah mm-hmm
now the great thing about kasam pie is
the fact that they do everything
in-house like I mentioned that the
house-made brioche bun is done in-house
obviously but even their patties isn't
some kind of frozen patty that they just
stuck on together they got from another
butcher they actually grind their own
meat and they had their own percentage
of whatever brief that they're using and
whatever amount of fat so you can really
taste like the handcrafted miss in this
burger
mm sometimes when it comes to food like
personally I love vegetables but other
times you don't want something vegetable
on your burger dude you just want
something to be so guilty so fatty and
anxious this brother right here is gonna
do it for you you know Sam you know a
place is good when you got a freakin
electus sauce off your fingers now after
all is said and done this right here
this last piece of the burger is my
favorite part why do you ask is because
this is what you're gonna do if you get
it to go obviously in this delicious
miss on the bottom you are gonna take
whatever is left of that delicious
hamburger piece and all that yolk sauce
special sauce marmalade jam bacon bit
that's right here it looks like a
disaster but I gotta tell you flavor
bomb
[Music]
[Music]
oh I think the brioche bun is my
favorite I don't know the lady that
bakes this at Kaasen paya I freaking
love her because honestly that's the
thing that holds this whole burger
together and it's something that doesn't
just like fade away it's just not a
piece that's just gonna put everything
you know smash everything in between is
actually a highlight of the burger that
I love and I gotta say ain't nothing
wrong with this clearly my heart's not
liking you too much but clam magnifique
next up how to take off my sweater
because we all know what happens when
you eat burgers you get the meat sweats
you so the next burger that we have is
from Cassell's in k-town oka sells is
like a k-town staple I guess it's been
around for a very long time and recently
just like a few years ago they went
through a whole revamp let me show you
what you get with in this little
delicious box right now Wow right here
all the condiments they kind of set it
by the way if you want to go out and a
picnic in those the needle filled fields
of MacArthur Park bring this hamburger
with you just push the little [ __ ]
heroin needles aside but the cool thing
about this is is that the way they pack
it to go keeps the hamburger warm you
got your we'll start here you got your
catsup here and we got your special
sauce here and of course if you ask for
everything with it and there's cute
little plastic bin my friend you get
[ __ ] your pickles onions tomato and
lettuce
now with the burger echo cells you can
get it however you like no vegetables if
the whole fixings whatever it's all up
to you how I like to do it and let me
unveil the delicious hamburger that's
what you call a classic burger [ __ ]
nice and warm in this foil plastic Bunch
and don't don't don't don't throw this
away real quick you call this cheese
paper
people might judge you people might call
you fat look how I get my Cassell's
burger obviously I get a cheeseburger
cheddar cheese with it I add bacon and
grilled onions on the inside I take my
pickles I take my tomatoes like so then
I take my [ __ ] Bibb lettuce be a
lettuce player like that the raw onions
I leave it in there and there you have
it Cassell is gonna be a classic
hamburger done the right way nothing too
fancy about it it's just a really good
burger they don't freeze their meat they
actually ground it in-house and let me
just show you what I'm gonna do this
[ __ ] delicious dese meat sweats oh no
did you see that [ __ ] meat juice
right there that's how juicy it is it's
not cooked medium-rare anything like
that
it's just like the type of beef and the
amount of fat they put in there it's
just right and like I said before just
like what the cost of my burger
the button is freaking delicious grilled
onions cheddar cheese smoky bacon crunch
from that Bibb lettuce and that acidity
acidity from the pickle
[Music]
oh so good I was still excited for the
burger I actually forgot I don't put
ketchup in my [ __ ] but I do put that
special sauce playboy um we'll take your
bun like dis Playboy then you gonna take
that sauce playboy just drizzle it right
there that's that in how special sauce
real quick sandwich that down like that
see that just coming out on the edges oh
yeah Jesus Redeemer oh good
you know just realize about myself with
this baseball cap in my ten drop on I
look like a Asian that's racist because
other Asians get out of here swear nice
hamburgers to me as a kid well something
I always wanted to eat it what does
something that got a lot just because I
ate a lot of like home Korean food you
know so whenever I got a hamburger I was
always hiding about it because it was
American food that I normally didn't get
dip a little mustard there you know
we'll start mmm and don't underestimate
by the way having a little bit of veggie
in there because this Bibb lettuce right
here that crunch that little freshness
is what you need to just break up all
that fatty goodness
[Music]
you know what Cassell's does really well
[Music]
that's heart and that brown delicious
punchy fat meat that you get when you
just sear something on high heat what
I'm gonna do actually just take that
sauce hmm so you could build your burger
however you like it once again
I added the bacon I added the grilled
onions wanna saute the onions
you wouldn't a sunny-side-up egg to it
extra sauce however you like let's how I
like it
but wow what can I say burger mania mmm
we cannot have a conversation about one
of the best burgers or my favorite top
burgers without this contend on I'm
pretty sure everybody knows what
in-and-out is it's just it's a childhood
favorite it's nostalgia and it's a
classic hamburger in and out doesn't
ever [ __ ] up now there's always this
classic battle about what's better in an
out Shake Shack Dick's in Seattle but
for me I think all those burgers are
great but in and out to me is still one
of my favorites so this has to be
brought up but of course everybody gets
their in and out the way that they like
it so I'm still you know how I like it
from the top of the bag quality you can
taste since 1948 you had been pleasing
people since segregation has been around
we have ourselves right here this is the
way I like my in-and-out burger as a
four by four meaning for beef patties
four pieces of American cheese with
their delicious toasted bun pickles
tomatoes and animal style meaning their
special sauce in that [ __ ] including
grilled onions
whenever I want a good burger and I want
it quick and fast you know in announce
considered fast food it's not the same
compared to the other fast-food stuff
that you have but my friends I'm telling
you the cool thing about in and out is
that no matter which one that you go to
and there's are there are a few outside
of California it's always going to taste
the same melty cheese look at that
crusty beef patty just as good as the
first time I've ever had it consistency
is key within and out I feel like a lot
of the burgers that I've been eating I
really base it on the bun because it
seems like everybody else when it comes
to like condiments or whatever else is
inside people can generally do it well
but they kind of do like that classic
like old diner burger where it's a super
thin patty and you smash it down and all
that grease flies out and that's what I
likes mmm if you look at that right
there
it's quintessential this is a this is
like what a classic burger should be
like if you ever wanted to open up a
burger joint whether it's like no-frills
follow in announce model I don't know if
you can just because a customer service
is so good - oh and my favorite parts of
this - is like actually you bite it
halfway and then it's the edge part
because all that meat and cheese sticks
out at the end so the ratio is just I
know what you're thinking
David is a really messy eater listen I
don't care it's supposed to be a little
messy
a sign of a really good burger what was
like your favorite burger growing up I
mean in and out was the thing for us and
you know interestingly enough and it not
has like very like straightforward fries
it's just like sliced up potatoes I
think it's fry that [ __ ] it's not like
other fast-food joints where they have
it like pre frozen and I'm not saying I
just like the taste of theirs but it
announced fries are very unique and
usually people like them or they hate
them for me personally I love in and out
fries and I usually get it animal style
an animal stop by the way it's grilled
onions American cheese and special sauce
which is how I got the burger after you
get the edge piece you go straight to
the center me when you brighten that
briny pickle oh so good man
I've never had an operator where I
handed now when you get to this part
once again you got them double edges
baby right here don't throw away this
paper cuz you know it's all about that
cheese paper and it's been soaking in
that juice
the last bite is gonna be my favorite
bite so I'm just gonna nibble on a
little bit of these pieces Oh God
take that last big bite sometime my
teeth uh-huh
[Music]
mmm-hmm well lastly my friends is my
personal favorite burger of all time now
this burger was actually introduced to
me by Bart Kwan himself my body double
the pig champion is very special to me
and this is actually from a place called
guerilla mall I think and correct me if
I'm wrong guerrilla mom might have been
a food truck before not sure but is
heavy-metal themed a lot of their
burgers that they have are unique it's
super decadent very very heavy now let's
open up this [ __ ] to show you what we
got in side a lot of these burgers have
something very much in common and I said
it before if I'm say it again the but
this is a brioche bun crusty just put on
the griddle buttered I believe on both
sides delicious as hell that sunny-side
up egg is something special that they do
because they leave it right at the edge
so right when you bite into it the egg
yolk loses out so it's not gonna be
squeezed down and crush those spills
everywhere you Biden in the front so you
get that fat mouthfeel of that delicious
egg yolk ah you have a champagne
hollandaise sauce
Canadian bacon on the inside and of
course that delicious medium patty do
you see the thickness of this patty they
do not skip out when it comes to their
beef patties and they always cook it to
a perfect medium I've never gone here
before where they haven't cooked it to
perfection so let me give you the
introduction to that first delicious
yoky bite here we go my friends
you see that do you see that oh man
salty Canadian bacon delicious fried egg
perfect medium patty that is perfectly
medium forget a moment please to myself
see Jesus Christ thank you for blessing
me with this burger I love you so much
in your name I pray amen the reason why
this burger shines it stands out to me
the price tag you look at this burger
you're like oh it's about 13 bucks or so
but it's it's worth it and it's it's
gonna leave you full on top of that the
thing that made me really just draw
towards this burger was the fact that
this is a burger I could really taste
the beef you know what I mean like it
wasn't just like dressed up with all
these like crazy sauces and the
condiments didn't outshine it you taste
a anxious just beefy patty with it
[Music]
hmm if you guys have any other burger
places that you like out in LA
like you know république or this put
what was that joint called it's called
Salton something that they had a really
good burger out there to let me know
I heard there's like a classic joint on
Van Nuys it's really good too but once
again just the places that I like I
should I attack this middle piece
look at that color it's like it's like a
flavor rainbow right you got the yellow
yolk you got that pink delicious meeting
where I meet that yellow bun and the
green on top right there so we're just
gotta I gotta say - definitely a
buttered bun that's that's the key
that's the ticket
[Music]
mmm that bun - if you let it sit a bit
it absorbs a bit of that champagne
hollandaise if you don't what holidays
it's a butter sauce so they put a butter
sauce on already this decadent bird oh I
see what you're doing they're flavor
bomb
sneaking up to me like that no I'm Sam
yeah I'll see that and last but not
least that piece that Reza stones eyes
you don't know what the [ __ ] that means
but a lot of bougie ass TV chefs say
that [ __ ]
so then mm-hmm well you guys after my
heart attack what's something else that
you guys want me to try out or eat in
the LA area
we'll do a mukbang food review on it but
those are my personal favorite burgers
in LA always leaves me happy normally I
just eat one and then a week later I'll
eat another one but today was a very
special day and I have the meat sweats
I think grease is slowly creeping down
to my ass crack from the back of my neck
which is something that fat people
experience and if you're not fat you
don't know what that feels like but yes
until next time my friends on another
bulb on food review what shall we do
indulge me get it cuz this food is in
food is indulgent I have friends
[Music]